toos
Ecuador Pennsylvania New York New York
Chicago Chicago Chicago Chicago
oh the US facing a record number of
Migrant encounters at the border this
month joining us to discuss it all
former New York State homel and security
adviser Michael balbon Michael Bill mjan
my colleagues been doing such a great
job out in Arizona a few weeks ago I saw
the same thing in Eagle Pass Texas these
numbers we've never encountered them but
one of the things that Texas governor
Greg Abbott did early on that certainly
uh achieved the goal of bringing the
Border CR crisis to States well north of
the border so they would understand the
impact was to bust them to places like
New York in fact we can show you a
breakdown of the busing you can see
82,9 total Washington DC got 12,000 I
encountered some of those actual buses
and 30,000 to New York City now what do
you think about what governor Abbott's
been doing has this been effective was
it smart so what governor Abbott was
very successful in doing was making this
a national issue and when you think
about the the Border crisis and the
responsibility of protecting the United
States it should not fall to any one
state I mean there are literally over
the years millions of people who have
come across that border so how realistic
is it that the state of Texas should be
the one bearing that burden this is a
national crisis it should be a national
response now in New York City what's
interesting about that number Greg that
you talked about is that the it's 30,000
but yet there's over a 100,000 migrants
that have come here raising the question
how did everybody else get here and
that's really the Crux of the problem we
don't know who is coming across the
border or how they're getting here and
it's not simply folks coming from south
or Central America you raised such a
great Point Michael and that is the
impact that the overall crisis not just
those buses have had on places like New
York in fact I was uh shocked to see
this past week an oped from former
Governor Andrew Cuomo in the New York
Post writing this of all things I want
to show it to you he the title is if
feds and state don't take responsibility
for the migrant crisis New York City
should sue saying New York City is
already in crisis dealing with a postco
economy High uh vacancies crime
homelessness uh out migration in budget
deficits it cannot afford to pay the
estimated 12 billion in migrant care it
continues on the next page the city is
in is the economic engine for the state
and region if the Big Apple falters the
consequences will be devastated finally
culminating in the feds and the state
also mistreat migrants who are overc
concentrated in one very dense City
packed in modern-day welfare hotels
intense cities your reaction so this
really becomes the question of has New
York and Los Angeles and Chicago and
Francisco all put themselves in the
target for everybody coming in because
they are quote Sanctuary cities this has
really become a debate and there is a uh
a custom and practice and a I'm not sure
it's not a state law it's a city um uh
edict which basically says if you show
up to New York you're going to be
sheltered you're going to be given Aid
and what happened is nobody really
expected that to be to ever really come
into effect but yet what this migrant
crisis has shown is that the folks who
are coming through the Border they know
what cities will welcome them I mean you
just heard in your and the leadup to
this interview you had migrants standing
on the border saying so where you going
well I'm going to New York I'm going to
Chicago there's no coincidence that
those are the cities that are saying
were Sanctuary cities and so what Angel
quo is saying is in fact correct this is
a city that is not ready to do this
mayor Adams has been screaming about
this for the for over a year and the
city really is not prepared so now
you're talking about budget cuts and we
don't have the covid dollars that used
to be there and the economy is you so
the stock market's doing great but the
question becomes what is the future the
New York City New York State Control at
Tom denapoli has said we're going to be
facing some very tough times from the
financial perspective for the state
you're you're right that 60-day right to
shelter law is certainly uh been
standing the the test here in this
crisis but if we widen the lens a little
bit to go more macro and talk about the
impact and and I want to get just one
last question in with you on on this and
that is if you look at the number of
illegal immigrant family households the
center for immigration studies did this
studies showed that three and five 59%
of illegal headed households are on some
form of welfare American taxpayers are
paying for that Michael there's a a huge
question about
how what we're spending per migrant
family and what we spend on say senior
citizens through Medicaid and Medicare
there there's there's whole issue of
about what are our priorities are they
for folks who come to this country who
have not gone through the process who we
don't know who they are or should it be
to US citizens who are taxpaying and and
in the case of senior citizens and
nursing homes have spent all their lives
working and now they're not getting the
same kind of support that folks who just
show up in the United States are getting
Michael I just have 20 seconds I'm
asking everybody I bring on and you were
the New York h and security adviser what
one piece of advice would you give the
folks in Washington from President Biden
to the Republicans trying to come up
with a resolution here to get this under
under control yeah so so the the the
basic tenant of security means push out
your border which means we shouldn't be
having these discussions right at the
border we should be working with the
Central American government the South
American government we should work with
them whether it's monies into into
Mexico to say look have a better state
of security tell us who's coming across
better intelligence more border
enforcement teams that's what we need
Michael B Balon thank you very much
Merry Christmas and uh thank you for
taking time today I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis